Vale, ya estaría.
Vale, a ver cuántos estamos conectados.
Ah, es que somos pocos.
Vale, de todas maneras yo lo paso por
aquí y ya está.
Ejercicio uno.
Eh,
¿dónde está? En la en la plataforma hay
un ejercicio uno. A ver,
Cisco, no, pero estos son de Cisco,
¿vale? Esos de paquet, ¿no?
Actividad no evalues. A ver, ejercicio
uno, sábado. Ah, pues sí, sí que lo subí
entonces.
A ver.
Sí, sí es. Sí, correcto. Es este. Lo
tenéis ahí. Sí, sí, ese es el no
evaluable es
simplemente pues eso, para verlo mañana
para
ir haciendo, sí, ir a hacerlo. Vale.
Es el de en qué se se
en diferencia una red eh cliente
servidor con una
Correcto. Exacto. están debajos de los
ejercicios de Cisco,
¿vale? Y en los ejercicios de Cisco se
vamos de menos a más, ¿vale? Si queréis
vamos a vamos a abrir el primero,
el ejercicio uno,
¿vale?
Voy a abrir la aplicación
de Cisco
y vamos viendo cómo porque a ver eh
es como un manual de uso, ¿vale? de cómo
cómo ir creando diferentes
configuraciones.
En este caso sería el primero, un
ejercicio muy muy básico, pero sí que es
cierto que está que las capturas de
pantalla están hechas con otra versión
más antigua.
Entonces, a lo mejor sí que cambia un
poquito el en la la interfaz gráfica,
¿vale?
Pero vamos que que los comandos están
todos ahí, que es lo mismo. Básicamente
otro han cambiado un poco más a la
derecha y le han cambiado mejor la forma
de de algún icono.
Vale, entonces tenemos, a ver, voy a ver
si me deja iniciar. ¿Tenéis todos
instalado el
software? Este de Cisco.
Genial.
Vamos, vamos al lío.
Vale.
Bueno, pues esto algo así es lo que os
debería de parecer,
¿vale? Entonces tenemos con este primer
ejercicio
vamos a diseñar y simular de una red de
datos elemental, ¿vale? Y son serían,
digamos que los primeros pasos con para
que os vayáis familiarizando con
con el software este. ¿Vale? Entonces,
vale, en este primer trabajo vamos a
realizar la primera toma de contacto.
Eh,
vamos a utilizar la herramienta para
implementar una red formada por un por
un Hub y cuatro PCs interconectados,
¿vale? El nombre de los ordenadores
deben ser exactamente los que nos
indican. ¿Vale? En el en el paso uno
seleccionamos
en el panel de dispositivos.
Posteriormente aparecerá justo a la
derecha la lista de de javes
disponibles, ¿vale? Los aquí ha variado
un poquito,
¿vale? Entonces, lo que veis que estaba
arriba es es que está como cambiado,
¿vale? Realmente sería esto. Si si veis
pasamos el, o sea, aquí
tendríamos lo que son router, aquí
tendríamos lo que son diferentes
diferentes eh equipos, ¿vale? Y luego
realmente
para pues aquí aquí
tendríamos router, switch, servidores,
puntos puntos inalámbricos, ¿vale? E
internet, ¿vale? una un bueno, internet,
una una emulación de de una red one.
Bueno, no, o sea, si realmente es
internet, o sea, cuando pones esto,
vale,
vale. Cogeríamos el el este, ¿vale? Pero
veis que ha cambiado, ¿vale? Que aquí ha
cambiado un poquito, ¿vale? Entonces
cogemos, por ejemplo,
voy a poner así en las dos pantallas.
Bueno, en la pantalla los dos
programitas.
Vale,
vale. Con todos los esta manera de se
lleva a cabo con todos los componentes.
Es decir, si por ejemplo queremos
incluir un router genérico, tendría que
ir hasta el icono routers y luego
seleccionar el router de la lista que
nos ofrece el programa. Más o menos eso
lo que os he dicho, pero pero cambiado
de sitio,
¿vale? Se nos indica que tenemos que
montar una red con un con un y cuatro
PCs interconectados. Para ello se
arrastrará cada uno de los dispositivos
y se unirán con cable. Vamos a verlo con
en detalle, ¿vale? Una vez seleccionado
el icono correspondiente
a a cada dispositivo,
pulsamos sobre el genérico con el ratón
y mantenemos el botón izquierdo del
ratón presionado. Lo arrastramos hasta
Bueno, o sea, lo que viene a ser
seleccionarlo,
no soltar y llevarlo hasta y en el
momento que lo queramos dejar en algún
sitio. arreglar sí
ahora sí que podrás entrar ya supongo.
Vale, eso serían las opciones, ¿vale? De
de ese dispositivo.
Vale, lo siguiente, ¿qué iríamos a por
los
ordenadores? Poníamos uno,
dos, tres y cuatro. Dos maneras de
hacerlo. O sea, podríamos este,
hacemos control C
y pegamos todas las veces que queramos y
nos va generando unos cuantos. Bueno,
para para eliminar
tenemos este botón de aquí, ¿vale?
Entonces,
en el momento que que pinchamos sobre
este sobre este botón de borrar, lo que
nos, o sea, borra lo que tengamos
seleccionado y nos y se pone en el modo
de borrar dispositivos, ¿vale? Entonces,
todo lo que toquemos
lo elimina, ¿vale?
con botón de escape salimos de de esa de
esa fase. ¿Vale? Siguiente paso.
En cuanto tengamos ubicador, procedemos
a colocar los los PCs genéricos en
nuestro caso. Para ello, nos digo, vale,
pues eso, lo que hemos hecho,
¿vale? Una vez hayamos colocado todos
los equipos, tenemos la siguiente
disposición de elementos, ¿vale? Los
ponemos así, por ejemplo,
y así los tenemos como el ejemplo,
¿vale? O sea, es tan sencillo como
seleccionas y lo mueves.
¿Vale? Debemos a continuación unir todos
los equipos mediante cable. Finalmente,
el paso cinco, cambiaremos el nombre a
los ordenadores por el que nos propone
el ejercicio.
¿Vale? Para unir todos los equipos con
cable, haremos clic en el icono del
rayo.
Vale, esto lo que nos hace es crear,
unirlo de forma automática.
Eh, no nos deja elegir exactamente en
qué puerto conectar cada dispositivo,
pero sí que sí que eh elige el tipo de
cable más óptimo a utilizar. Vale, para
unir todos los equipos con cable haremos
clic en el icono del rayo perteneciente
al apartado conexiones del panel de
dispositivo. Justo después nos aparece
una lista con todos los dispositivos de
conexiones que el programa nos ofrece.
Vale,
no
sé qué programa nos ofrece. En nuestro
caso, pulsaremos con el ratón, el icono
del rayo otra vez que corresponde con,
o sea, de conexión automática, ¿vale?
para que el pack según los elementos que
tengamos elija el cable correcto, lo que
os he dicho antes.
¿Vale? Si eligiéramos este, pues lo
haríamos de forma manual, que es el que
nos va a poner, imagino. Y si elegimos
este sería la forma automática. ¿Vale?
¿Cómo conectamos?
Vale,
cogemos, pinchamos sobre el dispositivo
y esto ya lo ha conectado al puerto de
la tarjeta de red, ¿vale?
Y ahora, ¿con qué lo conectamos? Pues
con el dispositivo lo queremos conectar,
que sería
este de aquí, ¿vale? Y ese ya lo
tendríamos conectado.
Y hacemos la misma operación con todos,
¿vale? Nos venimos aquí.
nos venimos aquí, ¿vale? Si si pasamos
el ratón por encima del dispositivo,
vemos que los dos primeros faseternet
están están usados, ¿vale? Están son los
que
los con los que se han conectado a los
dos tanto al PC0 como al PC1,
¿vale? El resto estarían libres. Acá hay
una manera aquí gráfica de verlo.
Vale, vamos a hacerlo automático,
o sea, vamos a hacerlo manual en vez de
darle con el con el radio este. Si nos
venimos aquí y pinchamos aquí, elegimos
el puerto Ethernet,
¿vale? Aquí no hay no hay más, solo hay
uno. Pues ahí es donde lo tenemos que
enchufar.
Vale, enchufamos el cable ahí
y aquí sí que nos da más opciones. Os
fijáis que estaban el cero y el uno
estaban cogidos. Todos los que los que
nos presenta están libres. Entonces,
elegiríamos cuál el siguiente. Lo
lógico, a no ser de que queramos hacer
otro tipo de configuración
o que estemos o que estemos eh
conectando cualquier otro dispositivo,
que los podríamos separar físicamente
por colores, por grupos o por o
podríamos poner espacios entre entre los
diferentes dispositivos. Pues bueno, el
caso es que aquí iría el siguiente,
¿vale?
Fijaos que era el dos, ¿vale? Y antes
solo había dos, solo había dos puertos
fase ternet cogidos. Ahora hay tres que
corresponden a los tres ordenadores que
están conectados. Nos faltaría este
cuarto,
¿vale? Que ¿Dónde creéis que se que se
instalará? Si lo hacemos de forma
automática, pues irá al fase net 3,
¿vale? Que es el que el siguiente
quedaría libre.
Esto en la realidad hacerlo así también
cuando estáis conectando PCs.
Vamos a hacerlo de forma manual también
para que lo veáis. Pinchamos en el en el
en el PC, en el dispositivo
cliente y nos venimos a Hub, ¿vale? Y
elegimos el puerto S. ¿Vale?
Vale, entonces tendríamos
que nos quedan dos libres,
¿vale? Y tenemos del cero al tres
ocupados.
Que hace frío, ¿no? O lo tengo yo
siempre está así más.
Sí, no es que claro, es que puesto el
aire a 26, pero ya subirlo más.
Sí.
Vale,
queda claro de esto. ¿Alguna duda?
¿Algo?
Vale.
Vale, siguiente. Envío de paquetes.
Vale, una vez lo los tenemos ya
conectados, nos A ver si nos unimos
aquí.
A ver qué nos dice más. Vale,
vale. En este apartado cambiamos el
nombre de los Vale, sí, sí, faltaban
cosas. Vale.
Eh, corresponde con automátic conexión,
¿vale? Esto es lo que lo del lo del
rayito, ¿vale? Según los elementos que
tengamos, elija el cable correcto. Ahora
pulsamos sobre el primer PC que queramos
conectar
y luego sobre, ¿vale? De tal forma que
finalmente quedarán unidos por el cable.
Veámoslo en la siguiente captura. Vale,
eso es lo que hemos ido haciendo. En
este apartado cambiaremos el nombre de
los equipos, dado que es que siempre es
realizar exactamente
el mismo procedimiento.
Para cada uno de ellos se realizará solo
sobre el primero, nombrando por packet
tracer como PC0,
este de aquí, el primero, y
renombraremos APC1.
Para llevar a cabo el cambio de
denominación, simplemente pulsamos sobre
el nombre del dispositivo y podemos
editarlo. O sea, pulsando aquí, ¿vale?
Nos deja editarlo.
Y aquí le decimos, pues nada, lo que nos
está pidiendo que lo pongamos 01.
Vale, fijaos muy bien siempre en los
enunciados, siempre que es aquí es donde
a veces no sabemos un tema, no sabemos
algo, pero el enunciado lo hemos
lo hemos dado por hecho o hemos o hemos
entendido otra cosa y la liamos.
¿Vale? Así pues, una vez unidos todos
los ordenadores con cable y realizados
todos los cambios de nombre, la
topología de nuestra red quedaría
finalmente de la siguiente manera
manera, perdón. Vale, entonces esto lo
cambiaríamos a 01,
¿no? Porque como 01
es verdad, es verdad. Estaba yo ahí
liado con 02, que me había puesto un
modo fácil, como estaba el uno ahí,
digo, le pongo un cero y ya está. Vale,
este sería el 03
y este sería el 04.
Vale.
Vale. Pues una vez unidos todos los con
cable y realizados todos los cambios de
nombre, la topología de nuestra red
quedará finalmente de la siguiente
manera.
Vale, envío de paquetes.
A ver, una pregunta, a ver si
a que os a qué tipo a qué topología que
lo estuvimos dando el otro día, ¿os
recuerda
o dónde la clasificaríais vosotros?
¿Alguien
se atreve con
esto?
Pues mirad, sería
espera
con cuál la definirías más. O sea, al
final, ¿qué es? Al final es un la
estrella, ¿correcto?
¿Vale? que es un punto central del que
van emanando las diferentes las
diferentes conexiones. Problemas pues
unos cuantos. Si se cae el el
dispositivo central se va a todo
algarete.
Vale.
A ver, ¿dónde dónde estaba yo? este.
Vale, vale. Comprueba utilizando la
herramienta de envío de paquetes básicos
que hay conectividad entre dos equipos.
Realiza la simulación paso a paso de
esta conexión y explica lo que ocurre en
cada caso. ¿Vale? ¿Cómo hacemos esto?
Para realizar el envío de paquetes
básicos entre dos equipos y comprobar
que hay conectividad, utilizamos el
icono que corresponde a un sobre con un
símbolo más concretamente este, ¿vale?,
de que ya no está ahí en el lado,
está aquí. Sería este, ¿vale? Está en la
parte de arriba,
¿vale? Seguidamente pulsamos sobre el
equipo origen y finalmente sobre el
equipo destino. Supongamos que queremos
enviar un paquete desde el uno al
cuatro, ¿vale? Desde este PC hasta este
PC.
Así pues pulsamos sobre el, o sea,
pinchamos en el en el icono del del
sobrecito y posteriormente sobre el PC1
y últim y finalmente sobre el cuatro.
Vale,
vale, vamos a hacerlo.
Pinchamos sobre uno.
Espera, voy a ponerlo en grande.
Pinchamos sobre el uno y ahora sobre el
cuatro. Vale.
¿Y qué nos está diciendo?
Que no nos deja.
¿Vale? ¿Por qué? ¿Qué ha ocurrido? Si se
ha seguido todos los pasos, debemos
configurar la red primero, ¿vale? las
direcciones IP correspondientes, porque
si os fijáis, pues espera que quito
esto, si os fijáis, aquí no hay ninguna
dirección IP, no tienen dirección. Es
como si tienes un teléfono y no le has
metido una SIM o un teléfono fijo y no
tienes número de teléfono.
Vale, sí que están las las direcciones
MAC de los dispositivos, pero no tienen
una dirección IPA, ¿vale? Que los
localice en la red, ¿vale? Debemos
configurar la red primero asignando las
direcciones IP correspondientes
a cada ordenador. Para ello, solo
debemos hacer doble clic en el PC que
queramos configurar en la ventana del
frente que nos sale a pulsar sobre la
pestaña de config y luego sobre el botón
fase, ¿vale?
Algo tal que así. O sea, nos vendríamos
aquí. A ver, hay otras maneras. nos
podemos venir aquí, por ejemplo, pero
bueno, lo que nos dice el
Vale, nos vamos aquí a fase terne,
¿vale?
Y aquí
le pondremos una IP a cada porque no
vamos a entrar en, o sea, vamos a
asignársela nosotros, vamos a ponerles
nosotros el la IP que queramos, ¿vale?
En este caso vamos a para el para el PC1
ponemos la 192
punto 168.1.1.
Vale. Y la máscara de su no sé si nos la
si nos la calcula automáticamente,
¿vale? Eh, y este ya lo tendríamos.
Vale, este ya tendría su su número de de
entre comillas, número de teléfono
asignado, su dirección. Vale, nos vamos
al siguiente. Configuración
fase etern
estática,
¿vale? Y este, ¿cuál sería? El dos.
192.168.1.2.
Nos calcula la máscara de su red y
genial. nos vamos al siguiente. Nos
vamos, nos venimos aquí y ahora aquí en
vez de venirnos aquí nos nos venimos
aquí,
ya que es un poquito más como más
visual. Yo no sé si la versión la
versión antigua lo tenía,
¿vale? Y aquí le pondríamos
lo mismo, pero de otra manera. O sea,
interfaz el fase, ¿vale? Dirección, o
sea, modo estático, ¿vale? dirección
192.168.1.3.
Máscara de su red nos la calcula, ya
está. Cerramos.
Y el cuatro lo hacemos de esta nueva
manera también, o sea, para que veáis
que tengamos podemos hacerlo tanto desde
aquí
desde desde la pestaña de configuración
en fase ethernet
como desde aquí, que sería una manera
como más gráfica, ¿no? Con iconitos y
tal. de qué es lo que vamos a hacer.
192.168.1.4
y nos calcula la máscara de su credo y
cerramos. Si nos venimos otra vez, nos
venimos aquí a confi, vemos que
efectivamente está puesto en en la su
dirección IP, ¿vale? Entonces, ¿ahora
qué vamos a hacer? Vamos a repetir el el
paso, ¿vale? Una vez configurados los
equipos, podemos
podemos realizar el envío de un paquete
para ver lo que ocurre. Podemos entonces
repetir el paso que antes lanzó un
error. Pulsamos sobre el sobre
primero en el PC1.
Vale, ahora fijaos por aquí abajo
y luego sobre el PC4 que es donde
estamos enviando el paquete, ¿vale? C4.
Vale, genial.
Nada, ha sido satisfactorio.
Vale, ahora veremos qué es lo que qué es
lo que ha ocurrido y cómo.
Eh,
vale,
podemos observar en las líneas señaladas
por lo que os he dicho, ¿vale? La flecha
como indica, espera que quita esto
como indica que la operación se ha
realizado con éxito. Por lo tanto, el
paquete enviado desde el PC1 al PC4 ha
llegado correctamente.
¿Vale? Dado que Packet Tracer no dispone
de dos pestañas, una llamada real time y
otras denominidad, ¿cómo que no dispone?
Sí, simulación. Tenemos dos maneras de
ver lo que ha ocurrido en directo y paso
a paso. Ah, vale. Se referirá que se
referirá que no hay forma de verlo
simultáneamente. Realmente las dos
pestañas
sí que estarían ahí.
Vale.
Vale, estamos en simulación. Vale, abre
un paquete de datos y explica el
contenido de algún campo de la capa red.
Vale, realmente, a ver, para abrir un
paquete, estando en la pestaña
simulación, hacemos X en el sobre y se
nos abrirá una ventana,
¿vale?
O sea, sería esto, ¿vale? Modo
simulación
se nos abriría esta ventana y aquí
teníamos los detalles.
¿Desde dónde lo hemos enviado? Desde
este, desde esta IP, ¿vale? Hasta hacia
dónde lo hemos enviado, a esta, a la
1.4, que es el que corresponde al PC
número cuatro, ¿vale? Lo hemos enviado
del uno al cuatro, ¿vale? Hay más
cosillas aquí y luego tendríamos la
simulación. A ver qué nos dice aquí en
el en el PDF.
Vale, en el campo layers tenemos
representadas las capas 1, dos y tres,
pero si queremos verlo con más detalle
podemos usar la pestaña.
Aquí pueden identificarse varios campos.
Los más fáciles de de identificar son
SCR IP, IP de origen y la IP de destino.
La cabecera completa se compone de los
siguientes campos,
¿vale? Entonces, vamos a ver. Eh,
vale,
vale, del cer al 3
la versión 4 y tamaño de cabecera,
¿vale? Longitud total,
¿vale? Correcto.
Vale. Formato la cabecera IP. Vale.
Vale. Aquí esto más que nada son todos
los detalles del paquete que se ha
enviado. Eh,
¿vale? Contenido de la capa dos.
Abre un paquete de datos y explicar el
contenido de algún campo de la capa de
enlace.
Vale. Para los campos que se incluyen en
la trama de la capa dos se utiliza para
Vale, para sincronización. Vale, vale,
está claro. Dirección MAC de 48 bit para
destino. Esto sería eh
el SCR sería este de aquí, ¿vale? O sea,
es más que nada para que identifiquéis
dónde dónde iría dónde iría todo, ¿vale?
En en la
Voy a subir un poco.
Sí. tenéis calor, me lo decís o y lo y
lo vamos variando. Yo estaba ahí un poco
de lado,
¿vale? Colisiones. Provoca una colisión
en la red de datos. Bueno, antes de nada
lo que no hemos hecho ha sido simularlo,
¿vale?
Esto sí que sería dándole,
o sea, bueno, realmente no tendríamos
que elegir nada. Entonces, simulando
veríamos los el camino que ha trazado
el
paquete que hemos enviado, o sea, que
realmente se lo envía a todos los
ordenadores por el tipo de dispositivo
que es. Creo que el otro día estuvamos
mirando diferencias entre este y un
switch.
y vimos que que el switch creo que fue
con vosotros o sí que sí.
La diferencia principal era esa que que
optimiza, ¿no? Las conexiones el Switch
y te envía directamente solo el paquete
hacia donde va hacia el que va dirigido,
¿vale?
¿Cómo nos cargamos esta simulación? Pues
dándole aquí a borrar
modo.
Ah, vale. De aquí la quitaríamos de
Vale, así que sería. Vale,
vale. Ya estaría. provoca una colisión
en la red de datos y fíjate cómo se Ah,
vale, no hemos provocado una colisión.
Para provocar una colisión basta con
enviar.
En modo simulación, ojo, en modo
simulación, basta con enviar un paquete,
por ejemplo, desde el PC1 al PC4 y al
mismo tiempo otro paquete del PC2 al 3.
Luego empezamos la simulación con el
botón
capture y darle para adelante para ir
paso a paso y tenemos el siguiente
resultado.
Las diamas son la interpretación de
packet tracer. de una colisión, ¿vale?
Cuando os aparece una llama, o sea,
sería algo así como darle
y ahora,
¿vale? Entonces,
no ha colisionado. Yo creo que colisione
pues con más velocidad. No,
no.
Vale, creo que hay que hacerlo
en tiempo real.
No entiendo. Es que está mal redactado.
Bueno, a ver.
Vale, tiramos aquí tiempo real
y hacemos lo mismo, pero así. Y ahora
nos vamos a a simulación y le decimos
que nos haga las dos. Y ahí es cuando ya
hay conflictos.
Vale, pues eso, eso sería básicamente
este primer ejercicio.
Si
eh puedes repetir esto de la colisión.
Vale. Sí, mira, nos ponemos, espera,
¿cómo las borraríamos, Jorge?
¿Cómo borraríamos estas colisiones?
¿Cómo?
Eh, abajo,
abajo, ¿no? Aquí.
Vale, genial. Vale,
vale. Mira, cogemos,
nos ponemos en tiempo real,
¿vale?
Nos venimos aquí al PC1,
ponemos el, o sea, enviamos un paquete
desde el PC1 al PC
y volvemos a darle y ahora enviamos un
paquete del PC4 al PC1, ¿vale? y nos
vamos al modo simulación y veremos que
hay dos eh dos dos en progreso, o sea,
dos simulaciones,
¿vale? Entonces, le damos a al play
y es cuando nos aparecen las colisiones
que puede haber, ¿vale?
O sea, pero el rollo es ese hacerlo en
tiempo real para luego simularlo.
Vale, el siguiente.
A ver, este es esto es más que nada para
que practiquéis vosotros, ¿vale? Y le
vayáis mostrar porque lo cierro.
Vamos a ver.
Vale, abierto otra vez. Tenemos,
a ver, el siguiente sería.
Ejercicios de Cisco. Vale, nos tenéis
abierto hasta el tres, ¿verdad?
Sí.
Vale, el dos. A ver qué es.
Vale, vamos a interconectar
ocho ordenadores que incluyan dos Hubs
conectados entre sí. Cada uno tendrá
cuatro PCs. Llama los ordenadores de la
siguiente manera.
¿Vale? Algunos pasos básicos nos
explican con detalle en este documento
por haber sido ya tratados en el trabajo
uno, ¿vale? Me imagino será como
cambiarle las
los nombres y todo eso. ¿Vale?
Procedemos en primer lugar a diseñar la
red de ocho ordenadores con las
especificaciones que nos pide la red de
ocho ordenadores. Vamos, vamos, o sea,
voy a hacer yo este segundo y luego
hacéis vosotros si queréis el tercero,
¿vale?
Vale, este segundo sería,
vamos nos está pidiendo que
pongamos
primero uno,
¿vale?
Y eh bueno, y luego ponemos otro aquí.
Eso sería básicamente. Y ahora los
interconectaremos uno, uno a uno y otro
a otro.
Vale,
me pasó. Bendiciones.
Entonces vamos.
Vale, ponemos este sería el uno, el dos,
el tres y el cuatro. Sí, exacto. Vale,
pues
el dos,
el tres y el cuatro y el ja este lo
llevamos ahí. Vale. Luego tendríamos
el este de aquí,
este de aquí, este de aquí. Ya est
vale.
Vale. ¿Cómo nos está diciendo que
nos conectemos? Vale.
Vale. La configuración IP sería la
siguiente,
¿vale? 11 12 13 14.
Vale, sí. Este sería el 11.
A ver, vengo aquí sería
11.
Este sería el 12,
sería el 13.
Este sería el 14.
Vale, los siguientes serían, este sería
el
21,
¿sí? PC1,
el 22,
el 23
y el 24.
Vale,
vale. Obsérvese que que la selección
automática del cable
ha instalado cable directo entre PCs. A
ver, y y el correspondiente entre hay un
cable cruzado. Vale.
Vale. ¿Os acordáis el otro día que
hablábamos de los cables cruzados?
Cuando tú comunicas dos
dos dispositivos de las mismas
características, lo tienes que hacer
mediante un cable cruzado.
En este caso, al comunicar dos dos H, lo
hace con cable cruzado.
Vale, nos vendríamos aquí, lo pone
automático. Vale,
veis que ha cambiado la la
forma de la línea,
[Música]
¿vale? Entonces, ahora cogemos este
automático también y nos venimos aquí y
ahí nos pone uno directo, o sea, ese
sería el
un cable de red normal.
Vale. ¿Cómo lo ha conectado?
Vale, a mí cómo a mí me gusta, por
ejemplo,
cuando se conectan dos, o sea, esto
llevarlo así un poquito
un poquito como como máxima, ¿vale?
Si tenéis un dispositivo como un switch
o un o uno de estos, que estos la verdad
es que están ya en uso, tenéis un
dispositivo como un switch, cuando
conectéis los ordenadores,
conectarlos todos eh, juntos, ¿vale? en
una zona de esa switch, cuando conectéis
a un servidor o bien le ponéis un cable
un cable de color diferente o lo lleváis
a la otra punta del del de la de la
regleta, ¿vale?
¿Por qué? porque os va a ayudar tanto a
vosotros como al que venga detrás a a
configurar todo. Imagínate que el cable
que une al servidor con lo demás está
ahí del mismo color y en medio de toda
la maraña de que a lo mejor tienes 20
cables enchufados en el en el swit, ¿no?
Por ejemplo, una manera de identificarlo
y ponérselo fácil al que viene detrás es
hacerlo así.
Es bien código de, o sea, algo visual,
¿vale? que visual es o bien separado
que que a efectos de o sea a no ser de
que lo pongas en un puerto que no
hm cómo se me ocurre, o sea,
o sea, a nivel de de
una merma en la en la transmisión de
datos es que no va a ser, o sea, si tú
lo pones al final es si lo pones al
principio es que lo mismo,
o sea, es algo visual. actual, ¿vale?
Ten cuenta, ¿vale? Aquí continuamos con
esto. Vamos poniéndolos y él los va
poniendo,
los va añadiendo.
¿Cómo haríamos esto? Pues mira, me cargo
este,
lo que os he dicho,
¿vale? Y a ver,
esto no la quiero cargar. Vale, vale,
ese me lo he cargado. Vale, entonces nos
venimos aquí
y ponemos en el cinco.
A ver cómo los ha puesto estos.
Vale, porque estaba en el cero,
porque los he conectado primero. Vale,
vale. En realidad, a ver, aquí sería,
por ejemplo, del cer al tres los peces,
¿vale? Esto, esto último os acabo de
decir. Conectar los peces del cer al
tres, ¿vale? Porque son cuatro. 1 2 3 4
y luego el cinco reservarlo para la
conexión directa entre los dos entre los
dos dispositivos que son iguales, ¿vale?
Y aquí hacer lo mismo,
¿vale? Aquí en este caso, como ya se
quedaría todo junto, pues lo dejo sigo.
Vale,
vale. Más cosillas.
Ahora hay que configurarlos. el PC11
por lo que hemos hecho antes, ¿eh? Ay,
perdón,
192. Voy a copiar esto.
Bueno,
porque si no 192.168
[Música]
1 punto
2 168.1.1
[Música]
Lo copio.
1.1. Al copiarlo no me lo pon.
Vale,
aquí tal.
Bueno, lo hacemos así. Nos venimos aquí
lo mismo,
V, le cambio C2, S1 por un dos y aquí
nos calculan la máscara de su red. Aquí
hacemos lo mismo,
¿vale? V. Aquí le ponemos un tres.
Máscar un red. Lo mismo
aquí un cuatro.
máscara de azurre lo mismo.
Ahí
está
que sería el cuatro
másc.
Vale. Vale. Y aquí veis que cambia la
posición esta y aquí sería un dos. Vale,
tenemos
el 21. Este sería el 21. Sí. sería
21.
su red nos la pone. Copiamos esto
aquí
con
Vale,
aquí sería la dos,
aquí sería la tres
y aquí sería la cuatro.
Vale, pues en principio lo tendríamos ya
todo.
A ver,
sí,
si no me he rayado con ninguna. Lo
teníamos todo. Ya
vale. ¿Qué nos qué nos está pidiendo
más? A ver,
eh, ah, vale. Pin entre dos equipos. La
forma de realizar un pin entre dos
equipos ya fue descrita el trabajo uno.
En este caso particular se realiza un
pin desde PC 11 a PC13 y el resultado ha
sido exitoso.
Vale, bien sería esto que equivale a
esto. Ya veréis también. O sea, PC1.
A ver qué desde cuál hasta cuál lo está
mandando aquí. Del PC 1 al PC 13,
¿vale? Del 11 al 13. Vale, entonces nos
venimos aquí
y correcta. Ha sido correcto. Vale,
vamos en simulación. vernos el camino
que ha que ha utilizado.
Si os fijáis, este dispositivo es que se
lo envía todo el mundo, ¿eh? O sea, es
que lo propaga ahí
a lo bestia.
Vale,
paramos.
Nos vamos aquí a ver más cosillas,
¿vale?
que sería básicamente, a ver, cómo
del eh nos venimos a no
nos venimos
aquí ping
del
pin a ¿dónde? al 13, ¿no? El 13, ¿cuál
tiene? La 192.168
pun 1 punto 3.
Vale, enviados cuatro, recibidos cuatro,
¿vale? O sea, lo hemos hecho por
consola,
¿vale?
y así exitoso también. Vale,
vale. En caso de trata, en este caso, al
tratar de enviar un paquete PC al 4 se
produce un fallo a que se debe si
mantenemos el ratón unos segundos sobre
el PC21 nos aparece su configuración.
Vale, si hacemos lo mismo en el 14 nos
aparece su configuración, ¿vale? Podemos
observar que no pertenece a la misma
red, por lo tanto, no llegará el paquete
al PC14 enviado por el PC21, tal y como
confirma lación. Para que pueda enviarse
paquetes desde dirección,
bueno, dirección a secretaría y
viceversa, eh cambiamos la las
direcciones IP dejando la siguiente
configuración, o sea, los dejamos todos,
o sea, en este nivel lo dejamos todo en
la configuración siguiente, ¿vale? Vamos
cambiando las direcciones IP. Vamos a
vamos a probarlo de todas maneras, o
sea, vamos a enviar uno. Este lo
borramos
dos veces, ¿vale? Enviamos un paquete
desde el desde el 12 al 23, por ejemplo,
y nos falla, ¿vale? nos da nos da un
fallo.
Vale, entonces, ¿qué tenemos que hacer?
nos está diciendo que cambiemos esas
direcciones IP para que estén dentro del
mismo rango de de de la red. ¿Vale?
Entonces sería si aquí acabamos en la
cuatro, aquí
nos vendríamos a la
esto. Aquí qué tendríamos que poner
192 168
[Música]
1.5.
Correcto.
Vale, aquí pues nada.
punto 1.6
en la siguiente punto 1
punto 7
y en esta última
aquí y 1.
Vale, los tendríamos todos dentro de él.
Ahora si enviamos un paquete de datos
desde el 12 al 23
nos da el que han llegado. Vale,
vale. Hemos visto que este hub se ha
comunicado con este otro que que cómo
y ha enviado el paquete. Bueno, aparte
de enviárselo a todo el mundo, le ha
llegado al destino.
Vale, entonces
ahora imaginad que
este cable
es un cable
normal, o sea, un uno que no se ha
cruzado.
A ver, cuando cuando instalamos cables
en el
en un paquet trer,
la red hasta que carga, hasta que se
inicializa, a veces tarda un poquito, a
veces hay que actualizar, a veces hay
que, o sea, no es inmediato, ¿vale? Es
bastante
en ese sentido. Hay veces que hay que
que hay que esperar un poquito, no es el
caso porque este cable realmente no
serviría. ¿Vale?
Aquí tendríamos que tener un cable
cruzado.
Generalmente cuando ocurre esto se pone
naranja. Bueno, generalmente no.
Vale, entonces que sería
este del cer,
¿vale? inmediatamente lo
detecta
y ya se podría. Vale, siguiente cosa.
Vale, herramientas de Vale, utilizando
la herramienta de dibujo que incluye
paquet trace, representa una red como si
fuera un dominio de secretaría y la otra
como si fuera un dominio de dirección.
Vale, las herramientas
de dibujo de paquet nos permiten
realizar de diversas formas sencillas.
Suficiente para clarificar el diseño de
la red. Para empezar el diseño debemos
seleccionar la herramienta dibujar
polígonos destacada con un círculo rojo.
Vale, esta va.
Vale, tenemos esta,
¿vale? Sí, sería esto. Vale.
Vale. Entonces, lo que nos pide aquí,
por ejemplo,
es que una vez lo hayamos hecho, nos
aparecerá la el,
o sea, la ventana para de paleta de
diálogo, ¿vale? que es la paleta de
herramientas que nos permite dibujar
diferentes formas,
tales como líneas, círculos cuadrados.
Además de utilizar la forma libre, el
objetivo es realizar el siguiente
diseño, ¿vale? Entonces sería el
primero,
¿vale? Eh, ¿qué color queremos en el en
el borde? El negro, ¿no? Ahí aparecen
negros. Vale. ¿Qué color queremos en el
en el otro? amarillo. Nos venimos aquí,
decimos que okay, ¿vale?
Y aquí haríamos la red amarilla. Esto a
la hora de de representar
sus redes, bueno, mogollón de de
configuraciones, pues va genial.
¿Vale? Luego la otra, vamos a repetirlo,
la otra sería full, ¿vale? Entonces nos
venimos aquí,
le decimos
azul, por ejemplo, y un cuadrado. Vale,
aquí tendríamos
es azul, ¿vale? Pues eso, eso sería ya
tendríamos representada esas dos
esos dos departamentos, ¿vale?
Eleg
cuadrado. Clicat. Bueno, esto ya sabemos
todos dibujar un cuadrado
vale
importante
para etiquetar todo esto,
¿vale? La manera de etiquetar es con
este de aquí, ¿vale? Creo que cambie
también.
¿Qué etiquetamos? Vamos a poner, por
ejemplo,
eh
aquí ponemos secretaría
o dirección.
dirección
y aquí ponemos pues yo que sé estaría
cómo cambiamos si nos hemos equivocado o
queremos editarlo pinchando encima.
Vale. ¿Cómo lo movemos? Si si por
ejemplo no lo hemos puesto donde
queremos colocarlo, pues pinchamos y
arrastramos. Pinchamos y arrastramos. O
sea, no si pinchamos editamos, ¿vale? Si
pinchamos sobre la etiqueta, editamos
y no queremos eso. Lo que queremos es
arrastrarlo y ponerlo aquí dentro,
¿vale? Entonces sería, por ejemplo,
secretaría
y dirección, ¿vale?
Vale, más cosas.
Vale. ¿Qué nos dice aquí? Para etiquetar
cada sección como secretaría o
dirección,
utilizarán la herramienta place note,
¿vale? Que es lo que hemos hecho, ¿vale?
Solo hay que colocar el cursor donde
queramos escribir y proceder, repitiendo
los pasos para el otro lado de la red.
Tengas en cuenta que podemos recolocar
los objetos con la herramienta Sed,
simplemente pulsando en ella y luego
sobre el elemento que queramos
recolocar, manteniendo pulsando el
botón. Vale, esta gente lo hace, bueno,
lo hace, lo hace como toca.
O sea, eh tengan en cuenta que podemos
recolocar los objetos con la herramienta
seller.
Vale, simplemente pulsando en ella y
luego sobre el elemento que queramos
recolocar
pinchando. Realmente puedes hacerlo.
Quiero decir que no. Claro,
yo es que creo que ha cambiado un poco
la versión esta que está que está aquí a
podemos borrar si por nos hemos
equivocado de bajar la forma podemos
usar la herramienta
y dice nuestro gusto. Vale, si queremos
podemos añadir un recuadro a la palabra
dirección secretaria seleccionando un
rectángulo y marcando un fil. Vale, que
sería, o sea, seleccionando
el rectángulo, ya está seleccionado,
¿vale? Lo he movido
y ahora nos venimos aquí, le decimos no
fill
seleccionado,
el estaría el color
negro, ¿vale?
Y entiendo que debería hacerlo,
¿no?
Este no, no me deja. Ver. Y en blanco,
¿no? Pero que en blanco lo vamos a ver.
Vale, esto sería así y esto así. Nada,
nada. Cogemos, hacemos un Siempre hay
muchos caminos a la hora de
hacer todo esto.
Hombre, así queda cutre bastante,
pelado.
Vale, esto que sería a ver online.
Ponemos un negro, tal. Vale, es que
tampoco tiene más misterio esto.
No, realmente
igual.
Vale,
vale. Tipos de cableado utilizados el
diseño.
Ah, con que se lea ya va bien. Si es que
tampoco hace falta ponerle un recuadro.
Vale, entonces, vale, vamos a eh
tipos de cableado utilizados en el
diseño. Explica también de forma
razonada los dos tipos de cableado que
se han utilizado en el diseño. Cable
directo. El cable directo de red sirve
para conectar dispositivos diferentes.
Un PC con un con un switch. En este
caso, ambos extremos del cable deben
tener la misma distribución,
568B o bien 568A.
Vale,
esto llegaremos a la a la sección de
cables cuando
cable cruzado con este cable se puede
transmitir directamente a través de dos
dispositivos conectados entre sí. Esto
quiere decir que la conexión entre
dichos dispositivos no hay un
intermediario,
no hay un intermediario, la comunicación
y la conexión es directa. Por lo tanto,
aquellos equipos que sean iguales, por
ejemplo, dos Gubs, dos PCs, dos router,
deben de ser conectados con cable
cruzado y dos equipos distintos llevarán
el cable directo,
¿vale? Y ese es eh sería el diagrama de
de uno y de otro,
¿vale? Colisiones demuestra. No, no,
secretario, otro envío paralelo. Vale,
nada. Si queréis hacer el siguiente, que
sería el tres, tanto entre hoy y mañana,
¿vale? Y mañana y mañana lo vemos
también el tres.
Ese ya hacerlo vosotros.
Ah, os dejo ahí un ratillo aquí en la el
último cuarto de hora de clase
Dime
en todo esto
Los archivos donde está
tú no los tienes. Claro, claro.
¿Cómo vais a hacerlo? Vale, os los paso,
eh, por el chat.
Mira, voy a Claro, yo quería que
hiciéramos el ejercicio para que así me
diera tiempo a crear un drive y
subíroslos ahí. Pero bueno, os los voy a
pasar por el chat, ¿vale? Porque como
iremos haciendo más a lo largo de la
asignatura,
hasta que tengamos habilitado plataforma
y todo eso, pero ahora mismo me pongo
con el
Lo puedo mandar.
¿Lo has mandado tú, Jorge?
Sí. ¿Lo cuál? ¿Los tres o? Sí. Vale.